[Musique]
bonsoir tandis que le monde politique
est en effervescence à cause de la
guerre des chefs de la majorité
nous accueillons ici ce soir l'homme
tranquille du gouvernement monsieur
philippe séguin tranquille ne signifie
pas que vous n'ayez pas des motifs
d'inquiétude dans votre gigantesque
ministère des affaires sociales et de
l'emploi ne signifie pas non plus que
vous n'ayez pas de travail vous défendez
actuellement six projets de loi devant
le parlement mais tranquille ça veut
dire seulement que vous n'allez pas vos
états d'âme sur la place publique
vous n'êtes à l'est pas non plus vos
ambitions politiques dont vos amis
disent qu'elles sont grandes
ils vous voient déjà premier ministre en
1988 et cela quel que soit le vainqueur
de la prochaine élection présidentielle
vous ne vous étonnerez pas d'être
interrogés ce soir sur les conséquences
du conflit entre jacques chirac et
léotard un conflit qui a déjà fait
baisser la bourse aujourd'hui et qui
provoque un certain désarroi chez les
français mais ce n'est pas le seul
terrain sur lequel vous êtes attendus si
j'en crois le thé les sondages que la
sofres vient de réaliser pour nous et
dont les enseignements sont extrêmement
nettes en tête avec une priorité
écrasante des sujets dont les français
souhaitent que vouloir parler ce soir
69% ex-aequo les moyens de lutter contre
le chômage et les récentes mesures sur
la sécurité sociale et ensuite à 61%
l'avenir l'avenir de la protection
sociale cet avenir qui est un peu
escamoté dans les dernières décisions
que vous avez prises alors par vous par
vos fonctions monsieur le ministre vous
êtes le protecteur du travail et de la
santé ors du travail il y en a de moins
en moins dans ce pays et la santé
elles nous coûtent de plus en plus cher
y aura-t-il de nouveau un jour un emploi
pour chaque français
avez vous des idées sur la façon
d'inverser la logique infernale de notre
système de santé qui fait que personne
ni ceux qui se font soigner ni ceux qui
soignent n'a vraiment intérêt à choisir
la filière de soins la moins coûteuse
alors sur tous ces problèmes et et sur
bien d'autres
les questions d'alain duhamel
2 claude cabanes rédacteur en chef de
l'humanité d' albert du roy directeur
nouveau directeur de la rédaction de
l'expansion et bien sûr le concours des
téléspectateurs dont jean-louis la scène
se fera comme à l'accoutumée
l'interprète à vous svp avoue jean-louis
le sel qui il signe un bon soir et bien
sûr il ya ce soir pour vous beaucoup de
questions sur les querelles qui agitent
la majorité est principalement les cas
noir et léotard bien sûr on vous
interroge sur la cohabitation sur votre
itinéraire politique sur votre avenir
personnel
mais avant tout il ya des questions qui
s'adresse au ministre des affaires
sociales et de l'emploi avec un intérêt
numéro un est d'actualité
le déficit de la sécurité sociale par
exemple pourquoi ne pas attribuer les
sommes de la vignette automobile ou
redressement des c'est sous pourquoi le
régime des salariés doit tu le comprends
qu'on pensait obligatoirement le déficit
des autres régimes
mais la première question que je
voudrais vous poser est celle d'une
retraitée d'angoulême ne peut-on
remettre en vigueur l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes pour combler le déficit
de la sécu ou prélevée sur les bénéfices
réalisés par l'état lors des
privatisations
donc il ya deux questions de questions
d'une pour ce qui concerne les recettes
des privatisations la réponse est non le
gouvernement a fait un choix il s'y
tient à savoir que 70 % des recettes des
privatisations sont affectés à son
propre désendettement vis-à-vis des
français et d'autre part pour ce qui
concerne les 30% restants ils sont
affectés aux entreprises publiques en
fonds propres pour ce qui concerne
maintenant l'impôt sur les grandes
fortunes
je voudrais dire ce sont deux raisons
qui font que nous ne choisirons pas de
le rétablir
d'abord parce que le rapport de l'impôt
sur les grandes fortunes et sans commune
mesure avec l'ampleur du déficit
auxquels nous sommes confrontés même si
on s'en tient au déficit d'ici à la fin
de l'année évalués par les sages à 15
milliards de francs et ça s'appelle
tiers comme c'est largement c'est
l'harmonie supérieur aux 4 milliards que
rapporterait l'impôt sur les grandes
fortunes puis il ya une deuxième raison
c'est que si nous avons supprimé l'impôt
sur les contres arthur c'est parce que
cet impôt d'abord était un impôt injuste
je pense à certaines exonérations je
pense aux oeuvres d'art pourquoi ton
exonérer les oeuvres d'art et ensuite
parce que cet impôt est un impôt était
un impôt anti économique dans la mesure
où ils peser sur l'outil travail sur sur
la bourse sur les actions les
obligations c'est à dire les finalement
le financement des entreprises sur le
logement c'est à dire l'activité du
bâtiment des travaux publics
donc pour toutes ces raisons je ne suis
pas certain que le rétablissement de vie
gf aurait été une bonne mesure bien je
sens qu'on reviendra là dessus je suis
pas sûr que votre réponse et sa 10è
claude cabanes alors tout de suite
alain duhamel pour un quart d'heure
on s'arme ce mini dit ma porte pour un
gaulliste comme vous ça doit être
absolument épouvantable d'avoir fait son
entrée dans le premier gouvernement
depuis près de 30 ans qui soit le régime
des partis il faut précisément éviter
que ce soit l'origine de partie je crois
que c'est ce que je cherche à éviter le
premier ministre bon quand vous voyez on
va pas rester tout le temps là dessus
naturel nombreux hommes soit d'après
leurs voeux passe redoublée mais ça
c'est pas une raison
c'est pas une raison parce qu'il ya
aussi l'actualité qui commande et puis
vous êtes peut-être la rangée avec la
sofres
alors quand on voit des ministes qui
tiennent des propos contradictoires
quand on voit le premier ministre qui
est obligé de présenter ou qui se
croient obligés de présenter un
ultimatum un de ses principaux ministres
quand on voit des membres du
gouvernement qui sont autant de chefs de
partis et qui sont entrés au
gouvernement en tant que chef de parti
pas par hasard ou par inadvertance
est ce que vous trouvez que ça
correspond à la logique de la vème
république est ce que vous trouvez que
ça correspond aux habitudes
non certainement pas soit ne
correspondent ni à la logique de nos
habitudes de la vème république
la cohabitation la cohabitation n'est
dit dans les habitudes ni dans la
logique public
c'est ce laisser-passer mitterrand qui
assurerait à jacques chirac devant des
chefs de tribus la cohabitation est
quelque chose d'incontournable
non mais c'est la cohabitation qui a
conduit le premier ministre à choisir
d'intégrer dans son gouvernement les
chefs de parti pourquoi parce que sous
le régime de la cohabitation puisqu'il
faut en parler et nous avons eu
l'occasion déjà dans discourir monsieur
n'était pas d'accord avec moi sur ce
point celui hamel la légitimité du
gouvernement ne procède pas comme
d'habitude du président d'acs
elle procède de la majorité
parlementaire et dans ces conditions dès
lors qu'on estime nécessaire souhaitable
de constituer un gouvernement est de
gouverner il faut bien en tenir compte
alors cela étant dit oui cela étant dit
s'il était me semble-t-il indispensable
inévitable de faire entrer des
responsables de partis en tant que tel
au sein du gouvernement
c'est ensuite
touche autant qu'ils sont de veiller à
ce que leurs expressions en tant que
chef de parti ne soit pas incompatible
avec le minimum de solidarité qu'on doit
attendre d'un gouvernement responsable
quand il ya dix jours jacques chirac
lui-même se faire élire président du rpr
quand il ya le présent du cds swaps
interrégional du parti républicain etc
et surtout quand les ministres tient
avec d'ailleurs une grande continuité
d'esprit des propos publiquement
contradictoires je cite monsieur le
président de la république on me fera
plaisir à claire sur les bords d'un lac
je ne sais si c'était la clé m'enfin peu
importe qu'il était difficile à un
ministre ne pas être également un homme
politique
bon alors cette crise elle inquiète vous
ne vous inquiète pas parce que vous avez
l'air un petit peu comme ça de la
prendre à la légère
non je ne la prend pas à la légère je
crois qu'il faut dédramatiser il faut
dédramatiser cas qu'a dit le premier
ministre il a dit et il a dit d'ailleurs
à l'ensemble de ses ministres à travers
celui qui a été désigné en l'occurrence
françois léotard françois léotard ai dit
vos magazines journaux français il a
rappelé la rappeler 3 nécessité pour
tous man 3 devoir pour tout membre du
gouvernement
le premier devoir c'est ne rien faire ou
ne rien dire qui soit de nature à
compromettre l'union de la majorité
deuxième de voir ne pas se lancer dans
une campagne présidentielle prématurée
c'est en 1988 vers l'ami 4 à 8 on aura
bien le temps en janvier 2 6 m et enfin
troisième devoir consacrer toute son
énergie à l'action gouvernementale parce
qu'après tout il faut être logique
nous avons choisi malgré les
inconvénients vous avez bien voulu
rappeler en l'occurrence la cohabitation
2 gouverner eh bien il faut que nous
gouvernons on sait ce que les français
c'est ce que les français attendent il y
a d'ailleurs dans ce pays
une maladie qui ne date pas du 16 mars
1986 et qui consiste chaque fois qu'une
élection est terminée préparer
l'élection suivante
mais entre des élections il ya quand
même les devoir assumer c'est faire ce
pour quoi on a été
n'a été élu pour gouverner la france on
a estimé que deux années sans
gouvernement deux années de désordre
c'était plus que ne pouvaient ont
supporté le pays
donc il faut gouverne qu'est-ce que vous
conseillez à françois léotard de faire
beaucoup je me demande bien pourquoi
mais mal je vous aime gordon et l'autre
en chef êtes passé par aucun conseil
donné alors qu'est-ce que vous et
françois léotard s'est donnée quelques
jours de réflexion sur ce que lui faire
injure que de chercher à peser sur son
choix
ah bon d'autant que je n'ai pas
forcément tous les éléments
d'appréciation est ce que votre épouse
est un peu prudent et un peu en retrait
en retrait parce que le cas moi je vous
connais les journalistes vous connaître
quelqu'un général vous parlez plutôt
directement mais c'est le même là vous
êtes comme ça on a l'impression qu'ils
rebaptisent gouvernement si je
souhaitais batifolait comme qui le
suggérait comme le suggérait avant
résultats essentiels et en parler de
ceci ou cela je ne serai pas au
gouvernement un gouvernement c'est fait
c'est fait pour travailler l'efficacité
de l'action gouvernementale elle tient à
l'unité à la solidarité du gouvernement
et je m'impose ces disciplines
c'est pas toujours facile monsieur jobs
a une incidence est ce que vous trouvez
que comme responsable constitutionnelles
et politiques de l'unité du gouvernement
jacques chirac réussit bien depuis un an
ça c'est une question précise jacques
chirac a eu l'immense mérite d'accepter
de gouverner dans des circonstances
exceptionnellement difficile
exceptionnellement difficile sur le plan
économique on y reviendra probablement
social
exceptionnellement difficile sur le plan
institutionnel cette situation de
cohabitation exceptionnellement
difficile sur le plan politique compte
tenu de la proximité des élections
présidentielles il aurait pu après tout
comme d'autres restent
prudemment en retrait il a choisit de
gouverner il a choisi de prendre ses
responsabilités ce faisant moi je crois
qu'il a conforté sa stature d'homme
d'état et que les français ne manqueront
pas un jour où l'eau de lui rendre
justice
alors ça c'est une réponse n'était pas
une réponse à ma question parce que ma
question c'était pas du tout ça c'était
pas est ce que ça vous aurez compris que
je ne porte pas sur l'action de jacques
chirac à mon propos comme responsable
l'appréciation immédiate et
gouvernementales comme responsable de
l'unité gouvernementale vous trouvez
qu'il réussit bien il fait ce qu'il doit
faire et l'événement d'hier et la poule
2 montre bien comment est ce que vous
expliquez que dès que la droite est au
pouvoir immédiatement ses chefs
commencent à se quereller
on écoute ne faudrait pas ne faudrait
pas donner à penser que la proximité des
élections présidentielles ne très de
perturbations qu'au sein de la majorité
vous observez 10 ans en voyant
communiste ce cabane pourrait le
confirmer on parle d'un candidat
officiel et d'un certain mais qui sera
également candidat au parti socialiste
monsieur mitterrand des pas candidate
dans les temps monsieur rocard l'était
également
il y acquiert qu'à l'extrême droite que
les choses soient relativement perd
encore qu'on nous annonce un ou deux
candidats dissidents
je pense que ce sont des choses qui
arrivent à l'échéance présidentielle
régulièrement
bon donc d'être tranquille où je suis
tranquille je crois que ce dont il faut
se préoccuper
ce sont des dossiers qui sont les
dossiers d'affronter leurs dernières
questions politiques michel noir votre
collègue au gouvernement
voilà nom et votre ami ben a fortiori
heures à parler à votre sujet de silence
radio à propos de votre réserve
publiques tenues sur jean marie lebel
jeu et défauts ça ce noir ne pas
confiance en tous cas a priori dix 10
ans que dans cette période beaucoup de
ministres de votre génération se sont
exprimés et compris madame arzacq etc et
d'autre vous vous êtes occupé de vos
dossiers et vous avez travaillé mais
vous n'aviez rien à dire vous ne vouliez
rien dire écoutée dans la semaine en
question j'ai dû m'opposer entre 60 et
70 fois aux positions exprimées par le
front national
pourquoi parce que j'étais à l'assemblée
nationale et sous un déluge
d'amendements provenant du front
national qui voulait créer une sécurité
sociale spéciale pour les immigrés
réserver les emplois aux français aux
habitants de la communauté économique
européenne et c'est donc pour en revenir
au fond il n'y a rien dans le propos de
michel noir dans son article au monde au
mont pour ne pas le citer qui était de
nature à me choque et en revanche
pensent que se posait un problème de
méthode
je crois que ces idées-là ses idées
d'extrême droite il faut les combattre
moubarak dossier par dossier
et ne pas se lancer dans des
proclamations qui peuvent faire plaisir
sur l'instant mais qui sont finalement
d'une moindre efficacité
je crois qu'il ne faut pas rentrer dans
le jeu du responsable de l'extrême
droite auquel nous pensons tous les deux
et dont vous ne dites pas le nom en en
faisant le centre de la vie politique
française je crois ce serait vraiment
réduire à peu de chose au débat
politique de le réduire à la question
suivante est ce qu on est pour ou contre
vannes droite l'extrême droite en
question je crois que c'est l'amiral
thierry d'argenlieu qui avait une phrase
que je vais rapporter enfin de mémoire
je ne pense pas je dois déformerait il
disait ça n'est pas parce que on part en
croisade qu'il faut forcément être
malhabile juste avant la mayral la rue
sauf erreur de ma part et est un exemple
de moins de soldats au sens le plus
littéral lorsque l'on pensait que le
choix que je fais plus fortune alors il
ya quand même une question qui se pose
dans tout ça c est ce que la cacophonie
qui existent ne contraint pas le
gouvernement en fait d'ici à l'année
prochaine quand même une dizaine drômois
dans notre jeu vidéo mais je ne prends
aucune peur non ça serait plutôt la
sourdine même je suis dit si je sors mon
travail est ce que vous ne pensez pas
que la situation actuelle crée par
certains ministres qui ne sont pas
invités ce soir ici en tout cas qui sont
pas sur ce plateau est ce que vous
croyez que cette situation ne contraint
pas le gouvernement a expédié les
affaires courantes pendant les dix mois
qui restent ce possiblement ce une
fatalité
est ce que ce n'est pas ce qui vient de
se libérer de son propos du plan de la
sécurité se fait finalement ce qu'il
faut éviter
il faut faire en sorte que ce
gouvernement ne soit pas un gouvernement
intérimaire et que ce soit un
gouvernement qui pendant les deux années
où il a en charge les affaires de la
france s'exprime complètement est-ce que
vous ne venez pas de donner le mauvais
exemple avec le plan de la sécurité
sociale vous me reprochez si j'ai bien
compris d'avoir suivi l'opinion des
sages en la matière non je vous reproche
je vous questionne sur le point de
savoir si vous considérez que le plan
que vous venez dès d'opter réforme
profondément ou non la sécurisation à
l'époque proprement parler un plot dans
nous avons nous avons
chercher et trouver des ressources pour
éviter d'ici à la fin de l'année la
cessation de paiement mais s'agissant de
sécurité sociale le gouvernement a fait
le choix d'une stratégie sur la base de
quelle analyse le gouvernement reste il
est je crois d'ailleurs que c'est un
sentiment qui est très répandue que les
réformes qui appelle notre système de
sécurité sociale sont tellement
importantes tellement profond qu'il ne
peut pas en prendre l'initiative
unilatéralement
après tout il suit lionel rappelons nous
rappelons nous la période de novembre
décembre les étudiants que nous at on
expliqué à l'époque lé dialogue et qu'il
fallait dialoguer et que sur les grands
sujets de société il fallait se tourner
vers le pays et l'interrogé dont les
modèles et dialoguer élection
présidentielle c'est exactement c'est
exactement ce que nous avons choisi de
faire en décidant sous l'initiative du
premier ministre d'organiser des états
généraux de la sécurité sociale d'abord
pour informer les français sur ce qu'est
la sécurité sociale sur la réalité de sa
situation sur les enjeux pour demain en
leur demandant par ailleurs leur leurs
idées dix années ne veut pas dire ça ne
veut pas dire que les décisions ou les
propositions qui pourraient sortir des
états généraux ne pourront pas pour
certaines d'entre elles être mises en
oeuvre immédiatement personne n'a
prétendu le contraire
je vais vous en donner un exemple dans
le projet de loi portant diverses
mesures d'ordre social va commencer à
être débattu demain à l'assemblée
nationale figure une disposition
extrêmement importante dans la
perspective qui nous paient un prix pour
mater la sécurité sociale c'est une
disposition qui interdit ce qu'on
appelle les retraites coupes aurait il
s'agit de dire on a le droit de partir
en retraite en soixante à soixante ans
mais qu'en aucun cas on a le droit
d'obliger dans une convention collective
un accord d'entreprise que c'est encore
d'obliger quelqu'un à partir à 60 ans
alors que cela existait y compris dans
la fonction publique
ça sera écouté nous évoquons le problème
affecte
du secteur privé pour ce qui concerne
les problèmes de la fonction publique en
termes de sécurité sociale ils n'ont
strictement rien à voir et on aura
peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir c'est
d'ailleurs un problème
bon on vous a opposé en vous oppose
toujours dans ces cas là le fait que les
mesures qui viennent d'être adoptées par
le gouvernement une fois de plus limite
le pouvoir d'achat des salariés et que à
la fin de cette année le pouvoir d'achat
des salariés aura diminué vous
reconnaissez après ça n'a pas été le cas
ça n'a pas été le cas en 1986 et pour ça
je vous parle de cette année ça n'a pas
été le cas en 1986 alors je vous en prie
monsieur duo mais n'attendez le 31
décembre 1987 pour savoir comment a
évolué le pouvoir d'achat des salariés
autrement dit vous pensez vous que il
est imaginable que le pouvoir d'achat
des salariés n'est pas diminuée avant la
fin de l'année avec les décisions qui
ont été prises
on va prendre encore annoncé vendredi
soir des noirs en tout état de cause
participer au financement de la sécurité
sociale ce qu'une façon au sud n'ont que
son pouvoir d'achat mais gouvernement en
arrivant là où je pense que vous serez
d'accord avait proclamé que son objectif
était de diminuer les prélèvements c'est
à dire les impôts et c'est à dire les
cotisations sociales
on a vraiment le sentiment honnêtement
on a le sentiment que en ce qui concerne
les impôts vous donner un mal de chien
pour surtout pouvoir arriver à tenir les
engagements mais que du coup il ya la
compensation avec les boucles et josiane
réussissant te complète du gouvernement
en matière de prélèvements c
les prélèvements ce sont les
prélèvements sur les entreprises
las de ce côté là vous avez pu observer
qu'en matière de sécurité sociale nous
avons été attentifs depuis le 20 mars à
1h pas surcharger les entreprises et
j'observe ce qui d'ailleurs met un terme
un faux débat qui s'est développée
longtemps y compris au sein de la
majorité
j'observe que nul n'est pas les
reprendre aux entreprises les avantages
fiscaux dont elles sont plus bénéficier
et moi c'est l'allemand moi c'est là
l'essentiel
dans la mesure où probablement un des
grands problèmes de ce pays depuis une
quinzaine vingtaine d'années par rapport
à d'autres pays
c'est qu'on a trop demander aux
entreprises par rapport aux autres
contribuables potentiels mais
l'ajustement moi la question que vous
posez c'est est pas pour les entreprises
c'était pour les particuliers alors mac
et au delà la tête vous l'avez
d'ailleurs très bien comprise mais la
question d'une machine certes pas vous
dire je ne peux pas vous dire à 0 2 ou 0
4 point presse que je vous rappelle que
le président malade y est de 0,4 et le
prélèvement publié hier ses 2,02 20.2 ce
qui représente pour un smicard si je ne
m'abuse quelque chose qui doit être de
l'ordre de 28 francs bon par mois bon 28
francs je ne peux pas vous dire à
l'heure qu'il est si au 31 décembre le
pouvoir d'achat aura évolué la madrasa
je vous demande est là c'est pas ça que
nous on et ça c'était la question
d'avant mais là ce que je ne sais pas si
c'est moi de chercher à répondre non non
je suis je suis persuadé que vous
comprenez très bien et que quand vous
répondez votre chance c'est parce que
vous êtes en train de réfléchir
alors ma question je la réveille en
éruption
alors bien sûr je la reine fait ma
question c'est est-ce que vous n'avez
pas le sentiment est ce que vous est-ce
que vous reconnaissez ou non que si le
gouvernement fait les plus grands
efforts en ce qui concerne les
particuliers pour tenir parole sur les
impôts
en revanche qui compense sur les
cotisations sociales
et oui en soit ça me paraît évident ah
bon et voilà
bon mais monsieur le ministre avant
d'aller à l'essai fait voir les
questions que le téléspectateur se
posent leurs études le prouvent les
résultats d'un premier était les
sondages
la question était au fond y at il à
votre avis un risque que le conflit
chirac y attarder boot débouche une
crise majeure
croyez vous que le conflit va aller
jusqu'à démission du gouvernement
oui 10% seulement non 71%
pas de commentaire je lui ai mail me
trouvais serein je crois que je me suis
je ne suis pas d'accord deuxième
question sur la la deuxième partie de
votre entretien avec alain duhamel c'est
à dire le plan enfin les mesures prises
à la veille du week-end comme ça très
rapidement pour pas affoler la bourse
sur la sécurité sociale à propos de ces
mesures est ce que vous estimez que le
gouvernement n'avait pas le choix et
n'est que ces mesures et qu'il a eu
raison de les prendre jouer ces formules
un peu différemment la 35% acceptable
53% inacceptables et le gouvernement
aurait dû trouver d'autres solutions
mais ça c'est pas du pourquoi parce que
pour l'instant je n'ai pas défendu le
choix qui a été fait par le gouvernement
alors ça c'est un sondage de départ
alors maintenant j'espère que je le
rencontre à l'occasion de défendre
j'attire l'attention de jérôme et
l'arrivée en regardant on refera à votre
demande
le même à la fin pour voir si vous avez
été convaincant svp une question oui
toujours des questions et beaucoup de
questions sur le trou de la sécurité
sociale avec celle ci pourquoi avez vous
éviter de mettre une taxe sur les
alcools à cause des lobbys sur sur les
mesures relatives au tabac et aux
alcools qui ont été proposées par le
comité des sages et qui ont trait d'une
part à l'interdiction de la publicité
surtout médias et d'autre part à une
surtaxe dont le produit serait affecté à
la sécurité sociale et plus précisément
régime général le gouvernement fera
connaître dans les semaines qui viennent
la position qu'il a été conduit à
adopter d'ores et déjà
il a pris la décision de prévoir une
augmentation du prix des tabacs à partir
du 1er août si je ne m'abuse dont le
produit et ça c'était vraiment une
innovation sera affecté intégralement à
la sécurité sociale ce qui représentera
quelque 500 millions de francs 50
milliards de centimes sont dany plein
pour l'instant je ne peux en dire
davantage mais c'est un sujet que nous
étudions wafo bien claude cabanes
rédacteur en chef de l'humanité pour un
quart d'heure bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
je me sens très bien dans ce fauteuil
virieu je vous en prie vous vers l'été
que je savoure une seconde parce que il
y a trois ou quatre ans qu'il n'y avait
pas eu de journaliste de l'humanité sur
ce plateau
alors j'ose dire il a fait face au
boxeur voilà voilà
il y avait bien sûr vous l'avez pas de
chance alors je voudrais replonger
allemagne et vous quand même un tout
petit peu de latin parce que vos genoux
vont taper dans les micros bien très
bien la balle je voulais qu'elle
revienne monsieur seguin sur les deux
dossiers qui vous concernent directement
j'allais dire les deux désastres on va
en parler
la sécurité sociale de l'emploi au sujet
de la sécurité sociale d'abord je vous
ai écouté attentivement bien sûr je n'ai
pas du tout été convaincu
mais je suppose qu'on vous a rapporté
des scènes assez poignante qui ont eu
lieu dans des pharmacies où l'on a vu
des gens modestes souvent âgés mais pas
seulement âgée être saisie de détresse
devant le fait qu' il n'avait pas les
moyens de payer ce que la sécurité
sociale leur rembourser alors et
j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment à cet
égard et vous poser une question plus
générale on dit que vous aimez la vérité
on vous aimez la vérité toute nue alors
est-ce que vous acceptez cette vérité là
qui est simple métier très cruel c'est
que la france de la libération
elle s'est donnée le système de
protection sociale le plus avancé du
monde et la france de 1987 celle de
monsieur seguin chirac et quelques
autres d'ailleurs elle entreprend de le
détruire et elle tourne ses regards vers
je dirais le 19e siècle et commence à
s'installer dans la société une médecine
pour les riches une médecine pour les
pauvres alors expliquez-moi comment
l'intérêt de l'industrie
alors ça fait de questions il gagna
précisions sur les personnes âgées et le
remboursement des médicaments à vignette
bleue
j'ai cru que c'était de cela qu'il
s'agissait et puis une question plus
générale 1945 1996 ce qui concerne ainsi
que si je voudrais vous dire j'ai cabale
que le gouvernement a été d'autant plus
sensible aux problèmes que vous évoquez
qu'il a pris toutes dispositions pour
demander aux caisses de sécurité sociale
de prendre en charge les cas que vous
venez de rapporter quelle a été
l'origine de la décision du gouvernement
il y à un certain nombre de médicaments
sont des médicaments à vignette bleue
qui sont théoriquement rembourser à 40%
il date de 1979 et c'est le gouvernement
socialiste qui a classé l'essentiel des
spécialités qui s'y font qu'aujourd'hui
ces médicaments donc sont censés n'être
utile le plus souvent que pour des
troubles ne présentant pas un caractère
habituel de gravité mais il est vrai qu
à mulhouse il est vrai mais on ne
l'interrogé pas parce que je vais
apporter la précision des âneries à ce
sujet j'ai un collaborateur à l'humanité
qui a eu un accident cardiaque il y a
un an et demi et il le subit des
traitements de longue durée permanent et
parmi les médicaments qui le doit
prendre il ya ce qu'on appelle le nôtre
aux piles qui est un médicament qui tend
à prévenir les accidents de la
circulation cérébrale ce nos entreprises
est classé médicaments de confort
j'avoue ma stupéfaction parce que
essayer de prévenir que l'on est un
accident qui entraîne la paralysie par
exemple qu'on se retrouve sur une chaise
roulante ou la perte de l'usagé de la
parole
est ce que c'est une fantaisie luxueuse
jeunes formés vous me voyez encore plus
stupéfaits que vous donne raison bien
simple c'est que moi qui vous parle
madame barbe monsieur zeller nous
n'avons jamais classe c'est un
médicament et 15% les seules décisions
que nous avons grillé menacé alors les
seuls décision que nous avons prise ça a
été précisément des reclassements de 40
à 70% sur l'avis d'une commission
spécialisée alors vous me demandez qui a
procédé à ces classements ne rien savoir
ce sont des gens que vos ennemis de
ministres communistes ont côtoyé au
gouvernement pendant trois ans mais
laissez vous me posez une question
jouiront dont là vous me demandez qui a
classé au rayon nouveauté le vase et
toutes les quilles alors c'est à dire
c'est monsieur bérigaud point madame du
foie et coûté 9 700 spécialistes de la
question des ministres communistes pour
les raisons que vous veniez d'exposer
les vinyles communistes ont quitté le
gouvernement ils sont restés pendants
ôta et jure que les assurés j'ai entendu
rerentre je vous assure que nous ne vous
en dirons nous ne recommencerons pas
dans ces conditions là je me permets
quand même faute avouée est à moitié
pardonnée je me permets de vous rappeler
je vous rappelle il semble avoir oublié
que le père fondateur de la sécurité
sociale et monsieur ambroise croizat
c'est tout ce qui est un ami a ni cause
ni la libération en amérique elles n'ont
pas de base les textes de base sont
d'octobre 45 me suis embrasse prosaïque
entrée au gouvernement en novembre
oui et en été c'est râpé duhamel pour te
donner vous vouliez nous dit ça en
permanence mais ce n'est pas vrai c'est
vous dire le droit
non non non non ce médicament ils sont
les intervenants et je vous jure qu'on
ne recommencera pas comment gagne
également aligné nous avons mis au point
ce que nous appelons un dispositif de
sécurité qui prévoit sur avis conforme
du contrôle médical la possibilité de
rembourser ces médicaments qui peuvent
s'avérer absolument indispensable pour
le traitement en effet d'une maladie
grave sous la réserve que la personne
concernée si elle vit seule n'est pas de
revenus supérieurs à 80 2430 francs par
an augmenté de 50% par personne à charge
à l'heure qu'il est les caisses de
sécurité sociale ont des déjà prêté
réintégrer ainsi quelques 82 mille
personnes ce qui fait que la situation
que vous décrivez avait probablement une
réalité en chantier février mais a été
aujourd'hui réparée et j'en parle
d'autant plus volontiers je regrette
d'autant plus la cip que cette situation
et pull et puces vérifier sur le terrain
que vous le savez c'est d'ailleurs un
des grands problèmes de la sécurité
sociale je n'ai pas moi la maîtrise des
caisses d'assurance maladie
je suis tenu pour responsable de la
situation de l'assurance maladie
mais en fait elle est organisée de telle
façon qu'elle a soudain autonomie alors
maintenant j'en viens au deuxième au
deuxième grand problème 1945 bien
précisément
ce n'est pas moi qui vais remettre en
cause la sécurité sociale alors qu'elle
a été créée sous les auspices sous la
présidence du général de gaulle d'autant
et vous me permettrez ce mot personnel
que la sécurité sociale très sincèrement
de ces cabanes je sais ce que c'est je
sais ce que c'est on sait qu'on n'est
pas ministre
j'étais étudiant j'ai eu des problèmes
d'argent
j'ai souvent fait la queue devant un
guichet de sécurité sociale pour pouvoir
toucher mes remboursements
j'ai quatre enfants il y en a eu un qui
a eu quelques difficultés lors de sa
naissance il a été sauvé par une équipe
médicale tout à fait remarquable ça a
duré plusieurs semaines
d'hospitalisation dans un service de
très haut niveau
j'aurais été dans l'incapacité de payer
ce que ça a coûté ou alors j'aurais dû
m'en d'été pour des années et des années
c'est dire que la sécurité sociale j'y
suis vraiment attaché à la fois par
fonction et par instinct alors pour
autant la sécurité sociale connaît les
problèmes
elle connaît des problèmes pour sa
branche vieillesse et elle connaît des
problèmes font sa branche maladie parce
que vous serez d'accord avec moi
monsieur cabane pour ne pas limiter les
problèmes de la sécurité sociale au seul
problème de l'assurance maladie la
sécurité sociale madame baraclude
ericsson harb à trois branches la
famille
l'assurance maladie et enfin la grille
l'on pense qui concerne répond n'est pas
ma question mais s'ils jouent à fond la
france qui sort de la guerre meurtrière
hui né peut se donner ce système mais il
espère aujourd'hui je vais vous
expliquer que c'est tentant de détruire
parce que le décret les décrets ou des
ordonnances pendant 1945 n'ont pas fait
que du jour au lendemain la sécurité
sociale a été créé ses rangs s'est fixé
on s'est fixé des objectifs et la
sécurité sociale en a sur lui à grandes
ambitions il a fallu attendre
il a fallu attendre le milieu des années
1970 vous serez d'accord avec moi pour
qu'elle soit général
99% il reste 1 % des gens qui soit
directement soit par l'intermédiaire
d'un parent ne sont pas affiliés
directement mais ils peuvent vous le
savez recourir avec des aides publiques
à l'assurance volontaire
bon il y a eu le régime général de créer
qui s'appuyait vous le savez sur les
anciennes assurances sociales ce n'est
que progressivement que les agriculteurs
beaucoup plus tard dans les années 60
les commerçants et artisans ont été à
leur tour bien sûr ouvert la marque la
sécurité c'est calibration et du monde
moderne vous me demandez de bien
comparer la situation de 45 et la
situation de 87
saïdou les relations gens vivent
beaucoup plus vieux aujourd'hui qu'il
vivait à cette époque là est toute la
violence alors qu'ils ont dans les
paires dirigeants de la ville est passée
en matière de villiers est ce qu'on va
laisser passer
il s'est passé que dans 1945 on a fait
le choix de système par répartition
c'est à dire que une année donnée vous
avez les gens qui sont au travail
cotisent et le produit de leur
cotisation est répartie parmi les
retraités
bon au départ dans un régime de
répartition tout va bien
il ya beaucoup de gens qui cotisent tous
ceux qui travaillent il ya relativement
peu de gens qui toussent
mais au bout de 35 37 ans le temps
d'arriver pour ceux qui ont commencé
leur travail aux 45 à la retraite est
bien le rapport s'inverse et à l'heure
qu'il est et du fait notamment de la
prolongation d'allumer humaine qui est
d'ailleurs un des grands acquis de la
sécurité sociale côté assurance maladie
nous avons un déséquilibre structurel
sur les bases actuelles entre les
cotisants et d'autre part les retraités
phénomène qui a été évidemment aggravé
est accéléré par le chômage est
également permettez-moi de le dire qui a
été accélérée par la décision qui avait
été prise d'abaisser la retraite à 60
ans vous êtes contre le principe de la
retraite à 60 ans la retraite à 60 ans
est désormais un droit il ne sera pas
remise en cause
en revanche ce que je considère c'est
qu'il faut absolument
et d'ailleurs ça répond aux attentes de
nombreux français facile
ite facilité d activité à temps plein ou
à temps partiel
après 60 ans mais en toute liberté et
messi en a parlé en liberté des gens oui
alors pour ce qui concerne maintenant la
maladie pour ce qui concerne la maladie
nous sommes nous avons effectivement un
système ne se cavale qui est le meilleur
du monde
pourquoi parce que nous sommes
probablement le seul pays du monde qui
réussissent à concilier une protection
sociale généralisée et un mode de
distribution des soins fondés sur les
principes de liberté
nous sommes un des derniers pays au
monde et probablement le dernier
prenez deux exemples vous trompez pas
mais enfin ils sont parlants les états
unis et d'autre part le royaume-uni les
etats-unis ont un système de
distribution des soins fondés sur les
principes de liberté mais ils n'ont pas
de protection sociale généralisée en
angleterre au royaume uni c'est la der
il y à la protection sociale généralisée
mais il n'y a pas la liberté on ne
choisit pas son médecin on ne choisit
pas son établissement genevois réuni ce
que je dis pas ce que je dis ce que je
dis c'est qu'il est très difficile
d'assurer les équilibres financiers
libres financiers auxquels nous sommes
condamnés par les contraintes
économiques et que nous devons
conséquence trouver des moyens de
régulation pour éviter l'emballement du
système alors on y vient les mesures que
vous avez présenté votre gouvernement
dante et vendredi d'ailleurs un peu
rasant les murs girieu le site à l'heure
à 22 heures vendredi soir pendant le
pont de l'ascension
c'était pas très brillant on n'a vu
aucun ministre mettre le nez à la
fenêtre sur ces questions pour donner
aux avancées sur cette avenue au spectro
télévision en radio de quoi il en
retourne
l'avion a alors rappelé le poids du tout
j'ai trouvé que la décision a été prise
peu avant 21h et le premier ministre a
estimé qu'il était nécessaire sans plus
attendre de l'annoncé devrait peser à
l'avenir qu'elles soient prises mais
c'était pas c'est pas une décision
facile d'aller prélever quelques 20
milliards waly faye orléans loiret et il
fallait des gens fument souhaitions que
la solution soit équitable recherchés
sur le plan technique les meilleurs
alors maintenant on rentre à la
répartition de de cette ponction
si on regarde les choses d'une façon
sérieuse
on constate que vous demandez aux
salariés environ 16 milliards et vous
demandez aux revenus financiers montre
cette vidéo
si le le 1% de plus l'augmentation de la
cotisation vieillesse plus en gros 16
milliards en revenus du travail 16
milliards puce et de l'autre côté vous
demander 1 milliard 700 millions aux
revenus financiers immobiliers alors ma
question est simple c'est un peu le
cheval est allouée à ces deux poids deux
mesures c'est le cheval et valouette
serez content trouve ce travail pour
ceux qui travaillent
ça va être très très difficile et très
dure
et pour ceux qui sont très privilégiée
ça sera un nuage qui va passer alors
pourquoi
quels ont été les critères qui ont
présidé un autre choix que nous ont dit
les sages des sages nous en dit d'abord
il faudra sept provisoire il ne faut
surtout pas préjuger des résultats
décevants généraux donc une recette
provisoire il faut d'autre part que tous
les revenus soient concernés il faut
prévoir de taxer particulièrement
certains types de revenus de manière à
atténuer la pression sur
plus défavorisés et enfin il faut faire
appel à la solidarité nationale
alors qu'est ce que nous avons fait en
ce qui concerne les salariés nous avons
10 04 points maladie 02 points
vieillesse ça représente en année pleine
un peu plus de 10 milliards un peu plus
de 10 milliards là dessus s'ajoutent
tous les autres assurés sociaux y
compris les non salariés
ça n'a pas encore été annoncée dans le
détail ça va venir je ne soyez pas
impatients de l'autre côté de l'autre
côté nous avons décidé premièrement de
maintenir en 1988 le prélèvement de 0 4
% sur les revenus imposables qui ont été
prélevés en 1987 par ce sont les revenus
et onu imposables qui paye mais ce sont
les gens battu au rythme ans parmi les
plus défavorisés deuxièmement le
gouvernement a décidé fait des salaires
a décidé d'y faire barman gouvernement
maintenant on va enfin grâce à la
politique fiscale à 6000 francs par mois
on n'est pas imposable
ça dépend la situation s'est également
la situation de famille un peu derrière
en très modeste qui ça dépend des
situations de sel deuxièmement deuxième
en dehors du 0 4% revenu imposable
deuxièmement on a décidé effectivement
un prélèvement sur les revenus du
capital financier et immobilier de 1%
un confort on reviendra sur le 1
milliard 700 millions que ça rapporte en
effet troisièmement on a décidé de taxer
les tabacs 500 millions de francs on a
décidé de baisser la tva sur les
médicaments 500 millions de francs
également pour la sécurité sociale et
enfin l'état a décidé de reprendre à sa
charge une dépense qui avaient été mises
à la charge de la sécurité sociale par
le gouvernement précédent mais tu
est reparti déjà je vous le concept là
je quitte le gouvernement il veille par
le gouvernement précédent en
l'occurrence les dépenses de
sectorisation psychiatrique c'est à dire
3 milliard 200 millions ce qui fait que
lorsque vous comparez l'effort qui est
demandé aux salariés et l'effort qui est
demandé aux autres aux autres catégories
vous vous rendez compte que finalement
c'est un effort qui répartit de façon
très équitable
est ce que vous connaissez oui il m'a
dégoûté images ou berger est ce que vous
pouvez si madame prima selon mme berger
non c'est de la fraude je ne la connais
pas mais j'ai fermé
non non pas du tout mais j'ai vu des
choses très très intéressante c'est une
lumineux tamaki je ne veux aucun mal qui
est actionnaire du groupe selon mme
berger elle possède 4 % des actions et
elle a touché au mois de janvier 24
millions de dividendes alors c'est une
situation que je trouve exemplaires il y
as d'un côté les salariés qui en gros
pet 12% gros sur leurs revenus bruts en
moyens en moyenne chacun peut vérifier
sur sa feuille de salaire et de l'autre
côté il ya les revenus comme ça du
capital qui eux sont très faiblement
taxés alors je vous pose la question
pour résoudre une partie des problèmes
d'inscription
une partie seulement est ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas rétabli à léquilibre bus
pour cent pour les salariés et 12 % dans
le capital
alors et cette dame nous secret vers le
gabon le contrairement à ce que
quotidiennement vous essayez de faire
accroire aux articles forte intéressant
sinon pertinent de l'immunité
la france n'est pas divisé en deux d'un
côté des exploités et de l'autre
quelques chalets l'élève maurras elle
pourrait prendre salariés l'essentiel de
ce qu'ils gagnent je vais vous le
démontrer qu'elle est en france
annuellement le produit des revenus du
capital
il est de l'ordre de 120 milliards quel
est le produit des salaires il est un
petit peu inférieur à 1800
cela veut dire que le rapport il est de
1 à 15 euros à 15 alors il ne faut pas
s'étonner dans ces conditions que
lorsqu'on cherche de l'argent on se
tourne aussi vers les salariés faute de
quoi on trouvera personne bien sûr me
lie à 18 millions de salariés environ il
n'y a que pour les emplois moulin
milices et en version est donc la
pression sur chacun des salariés va être
dans la vie de tous les jours ressenti
beaucoup plus n'ont en revanche ce dont
vous pourriez parler écouter selon vous
ne pourriez me parler ce sont ceux des
salariés qui vont payer 04 0-2 qui sont
fumeurs ça peut arriver et qui vont
payer l'augmentation qui ont des actions
et vous savez que désormais il ya 6
millions d'actionnaires dans ce pays
alors il fait dans une ronde on y trouve
beaucoup de salariés ce qui fait qu
effectivement ils vont payer souvent
mais écouter et j'ai un document là ce
n'est pas l'humanité sait c'est le monde
quelquefois le monde sérieux un document
est ce que la caméra de nos associations
dont le titre est entreprise
l'explosion des profits est en effet aux
lilas ce document des choses
extraordinaires comme le fait que la
thomson a progressé de 6 1% matras 232%
sommaire 103% et c'est ici et tout le
monde sait que à la bourse en moi
champagne tous les trois jours on balaie
on avait commencé ce monsieur vous êtes
encore là
en effet on bat les records je suis
encore alors la question
j'insiste pour y six mois est votre
dernière question non non non non
alors pourquoi je sais que cela fait
vingt minutes que vous et ce crime et a
expliqué que les entreprises sont en
difficulté il ne faut pas alourdir leurs
charges
or on constate aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup d'argent dans ce pays
il s'investit pas la production il crée
pas des emplois mais il gère beaucoup
d'argent pourquoi ne pas inhaler vers
une barre sous les abords de la rivière
pourquoi ne pénalise pas la spéculation
géant et votre langue que vous avez
exposé il me tarde alors adieu cabane
moi je me félicite des bons résultats de
certaines des entreprises françaises
ça fera le plus grand bien leurs fonds
propres ça augmentera d'autant leur
capacité d'investissement
lessard créera et sa renforcement
d'autres temps la compétitivité de
l'économie française et il me disait pas
la v5 et socialisme qui ont pris au
moins deux ans de retard en matière
d'investissement par rapport à nos
principaux partenaires et ses deux ans
il va falloir que nous traversions ferme
pour rattraper et la spéculation
financière ça n'existe pas l'argent pour
l'argent l'argent qui ne produit pas
l'argent qui ne crée pas gagné 10
l'argent l'argent dont vous ne parlez
l'argent l'argent des entreprises
l'argent qui va la bourse les actions ou
savez monsieur cabale les actions c'est
de l'argent qui se retrouvent dans les
entreprises les entreprises se tournent
vers la bourse pour se financent clan g
une question vers ie et la dernière
pilule dernière oui une dernière goutte
vous ne voulez pas toucher au veau d'or
soit alors une question est-ce que très
précises est ce que vous pouvez me
indiqué qu'elle a été la facture de la
dernière explosion nucléaire du mur
euros 1
je vous avouerai que je n'ai pas
exactement le chiffre en tête
je pourrais vous le faire communiquer
après un coup de jeune afrique seraient
moins sujets aux non résidents en allant
de la commission de la défense nationale
que présents sur ce plateau je serais
ravi qu est ce que vous allez nous
racontez là dessus cet après midi à
l'assemblée vous avez vos amis qui nous
explique alors que alors la tôle de murs
euros a été en dedans ou ou alors tu
restes janvier dans lequel la production
des d'armes chimiques
est ce qu'on peut avoir une idée de ce
qu'elle va coûter au pays et vous voulez
mettre en cause si je comprends bien la
politique notre dissuasion de la france
je voudrais vous poser une autre
question celle n'y a pas tout de même
quelque chose d' immoral et de
scandaleux entre les difficultés de
lassitude et sociales en particulier et
les budgets militaires vous avez fait
voter une loi de programmation militaire
de 474 milliards et là nous parlons pour
l'aspect social de 20 à 25 villages je
vous dirige alors est ce qui ne devrait
pas y avoir un peu moins de canon est on
ne peut plus le faire je veux dire mais
j'étais bonne pour que nous puissions
avoir la liberté de nous poser cette
question là il faut que nous ayons une
défense à lui fait cette défense je ne
vous la payer on sait qu'une réponse
simpliste
ce n'est pas une régression analystes la
bombe à neutrons ou les armes chez
merida une réponse le plan d'ici peu
pâle à défendre la france
le livre est sonné sans citer le
meilleur écoles propagande
monsieur gorbatchev actuelle les pour
autant vous ne ferez pas dévié d'un
pouce et d'un centimètre pas plus
d'ailleurs ronan que l'ensemble du
gouvernement est pas pu d'ailleurs et je
m'en félicite que le président de la
république sur la nécessité pour la
france la nécessité pour l'europe de
faire reposer sa défense sur la
dissuasion nucléaire
mais vous vous n'attendez pas le grand
souffle du désarmement qui va non non
non
mais vos amis allemands mario vos amis
allemands ils viennent d'accepter
l'option double zéro et alors vous
préférez une mais nous ne les avons pas
condamner voulait pas condamnés nous ne
les avons pas condamner c'est bien un
seul instant vers cela étant cela étant
bien bon de commencer mais moi je vous
en parle
monsieur gorbatchev et bien bon de
commencer par comment dirais-je les
fusées interne la portée intermédiaire
ou de 500 à 1000 km le vrai désarmement
par quoi passe t-il il passe par la
remise en cause de son système central à
lui parce que on nous parle des fusées
de 500 mille kilomètres des fusées 2000
à 5000 km mais qui peut le plus peut le
moins et les missiles intercontinentaux
ils peuvent toujours nous arriver sur la
tête sans difficulté même s'ils peuvent
s'ils peuvent aller plus loin en avant
mais attendez encore un mot parce que
c'est quand même une affaire une affaire
une affaire importante
d'autre part d'autre part les armes
conventionnelles doivent à l'évidence
être prises en considération pour un
vrai est complet les armements
alors le jour le jour où il sera
question de tout cela aussi alors ce
jour là la france mais pourra pas
question d nour a participé directement
aux questions afférentes là et s'il en a
besoin
ce qui n'est pas sur la table vous père
gilles hérit sur la table en chêne dans
l'aspirateur qui n'est pas sur la table
monsieur qu'avant c'est notre force de
dissuasion qui est un système central
je me félicite du relatif consensus qui
existe dans ce pays à son sujet et je
constate que vous êtes les seuls à vous
abstraire de ce concept une engeance sur
la faune d'initiation de normes et à
faire virer man online
une autre fois merci d'être venus
bien svp d'autres questions
oui monsieur seguin combien a coûté la
campagne publicitaire les spots télé
pour les états généraux de la sécurité
sociale à quoi ça sert et qui paye que
nous venons de voir d'ailleurs juste
avant d'entrer dans ce studio sont de
l'ordre de 25 millions de francs autant
que je me souvienne et c'est le
le budget informations de mon ministère
qui prend en charge
rassurez vous ce n'est pas la sécurité
sociale et à quoi ça sert à ça sert à
sensibiliser les gens sur les problèmes
de la sécurité sociale à leur parler des
états généraux et j'observe pour ceux
qui ne concerne que depuis quelques mois
il ya une prise de conscience
progressive de la part des français sur
l'urgence et l'importance des problèmes
de la sécurité sociale qui je dois le
dire n'était pas aussi n'est qu' il y a
encore quelques temps une autre question
aujourd'hui les scènes
oui quand vous déciderez vous a imposé
la robotique puisque celle ci supprime
du personnel ne remplit pas les caisses
de la sécurité sociale
alors se pose à travers cette question
un problème extrêmement intéressant qui
est effectivement celui du mode de
financement de la sécurité sociale je
crois pas qu'on puisse limiter le
problème de la sécurité sociale à celui
de son financement parce que ça voudrait
dire qu'on se résigne par avance une
progression illimité limité des dépenses
cela étant c'est leur est limité comment
vous avez dit à une progression qui
serait digne en progression il limité à
8 séances
donc il faut penser aussi régulation de
la dépense mais le problème des recettes
est effectivement un problème qui se
pose
compte tenu de l'évolution de
l'évolution technologique
alors est-ce qu'il faut s'orienter vers
une taxation des machines certains en
parlent
j'observe que ça irait probablement à
l'encontre de l'effort d'investissement
dont on rappelait tout à l'heure la
nécessité faut-il en revanche comme les
autres pays européens est d'autant plus
dans la dans la perspective de 1992 et
du marché unique s'orienter vers un plus
grand appel à l'effort fiscal
ce sont des questions importantes c'est
le type même de questions qui devra être
traitée par les états unis plus grand
appel à l'effort fiscal qui pourrait
aller jusqu'au système britannique
entièrement financé par l'impôt et et
médecine gratuite sauf ça m'étonnerait
ça serait vraiment contraire confrères à
la tradition française contraire à la
tradition française qui veut aussi que
la sécurité sociale s'autogère où
quelque sorte une jante en chacune des
branches
et pour qu'il soit légitime que les
organisations syndicales les
organisations patronales sont les
gestionnaires du système
encore faut-il qu'elles apportent leur
leur contribution non je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse s'y mettent dans les 15 ans
20 ans qui viennent de telles évolutions
sont possibles mais il n'en demeure pas
moins que sur la structure des
financements le problème est profond
depuis lundi on ne s'avoue que appelé là
dessus depuis lundi à sa tombe de
médecins a augmenté de leur propre chef
le tarif des consultations sans recevoir
l'aval du gouvernement il s'agit d'une
il s'agit d'un accord vous aviez donné
en décembre dernier l'aval du
gouvernement était de la première partie
de l'augmentation est pas la seconde
alors est ce que ça veut dire que vous
allez laisser les choses en l'état si
vous aviez vous allez donner tardivement
rétroactivement vote aval pour la
deuxième partie de l'année dans l'ancien
ministre a souhaité pour des raisons
qu'ils réclament psychologique qu'ils
échapperont à personne à l'heure où l'on
demande un effort incontestable
l'ensemble des français que cette
augmentation soit reportée au 1er
septembre et alors quid des médecins qui
l'appliquent
nous le saurons dans les prochaines
semaines bien alors un autre sondage qui
a été fait sur à propos de votre débat
avec claude cabanes l'objectif du
gouvernement en matière de sécurité
sociale est il de sauvegarder la
sécurité sociale 51% des gens pensent
que oui de la remettre en cause 39%
votre commentaire bon ça contient sais
c'est pas mal ça pourrait être mieux
bien alors albert du roy pour un quart
d'heure
nous sommes se doit les excellents
confrères et camarades me laisse peu de
temps et beaucoup de sujets abordés
alors si vous voulez bien on va essayer
d'agresser rapidement avant de parler de
de l'emploi au gouvernement du chômage
concerne une petite question qui nous
préoccupe est ce que aux prochaines
élections présidentielles vous
soutiendrai la candidature de jacques
chirac
la réponse le seul juan je ne voudrais
pas me mettre dans mon tort en disant
pour qui je vais voter aux prochaines
virus
autrement dit vous n'avez aujourd'hui
pas le droit sans vous faire menacé
d'être débarqué du gouvernement des
séries pour qui vous voterez bon il vous
soutiendrai plus que mon humour à si peu
de succès bon évidemment votre
projection vous prenez un gros risque de
défaut vivent dangereusement si le
premier ministre est logique avec lumen
il doit dire demain publié un communiqué
après vous avoir reçu et dire vous avez
parlé en nuages pesant contre l'accusé
ce problème ah non mais je voulais
savoir s'il y avait peut-être de poids
de news otthoffer tout est affaire
d'équilibré d'affaires depuis qu'on peut
parfaitement s'exprimer exprimer sa
sensibilité sans remettre en cause leur
la cohésion gouvernementale
j'observe une excellente legs monsieur
minery pratique cet exercice de 60
marques à une toute petite question
corollaire est ce qu'il vous semble
possible puisque tout à l'heure dans le
journal vous disiez je pense que c'est
que le gouvernement ait cette coalition
continuera à gouverner jusqu'à la
présidentielle
est-ce qu'il vous semble possible dans
les mois qui précèdent d'être au
gouvernement et de soutenir donc de
faire campagne pour un candidat qui
n'est pas le premier ministre de ce
gouvernement ou de dire ce que
j'envisage en cognant avance que
monsieur meniri que vous venez de citer
pourra restant ministre faire campagne
pour un combat
à ce moment là ce sera permis vous savez
on a vu on a vu des gens de genre par le
passé le gouvernement de 1974 autant je
me souvienne ils se réunissaient encore
il y avait au sein de ce gouvernement
des gens qui soutenaient d'économie en
1981 les ministres rpr du gouvernement
ont été obligés une très grande
discrétion dans la campagne électorale
par le chili
c'était donc de l'initiative du
président de la république et non point
de vue issus du rpr
alors le chômage les prévisions de
l'insee indique que qu'il pourrait y
avoir trois millions quatre cent mille
de chômeurs en 1992 questions précises
est ce que cette prévision vous semble
optimiste réaliste pessimistes ou
réalistes réalise si on continue à
raisonner sur des sur des schémas
classiques mais ce que je crois
précisément ce qu'il ne faut pas que
nous raisonnions sur des schémas
classiques
alors quels sont les schémas non
classique nous sommes en train de
changer de mode de croissance
beaucoup de gens ont l'impression que
nous sommes en train de vivre une crise
passagère bon mais ce n'est pas une
crise que nous nions pas ce qu'une crise
un début et ça une fin est ce que j'ai
un élan d'un emploi ce que nous vivons
un début qu'on peut situer pour la
commodité à 1973 mais n'a probablement
pas te fin prévisible c'est à dire que
le modèle du plein emploi stable à vis
généralisée qu'on a connue pendant les
trente glorieuses et jusqu'en 1973
ce modèle de société nous ne reverrons
pas selon toute vraisemblance et pour
diverses raisons ont diverses raisons ou
alors est ce que pour être logique avec
vous même vous
changez pas de titre vous êtes le
ministre de l'emploi mais je revendique
mois hautement l'abord le titre de
ministre du chômage parce que ce à quoi
je dois ma tach et pour ce qui concerne
l'attaqué peut faire c'est évidement
chômage l'emploi c'est l'ensemble du
gouvernement qui doit travailler dans ce
but
non ce que je voudrais dire ce soir
c'est que compte tenu de cette évolution
l'emploi l'emploi classique l'emploi
traditionnel dans les circonstances
présentes n'est plus qu'une réponse
parmi d'autres au problème du chômage
alors nous sommes en train de griller
les socialistes quand il disait ça
non c'était le communiqué les
socialistes défis clés mais ceci a été
quand on parlait quant à parler des
suspects qui étaient du toc
monsieur cabane pourra le confirmer
c'est l'expression était d'origine
communiste
nous ce que nous disions c'est qu'il ne
fallait pas se cantonner au traitement
social du chômage mais également
travaillé pour les entreprises et
qu'elles nous avons le faire puisque sam
était reproché le seul autre méthode
pour faire face à cette situation
essayons d'abord de comprendre le
comprendre cette situation passons sur
les raisons du caractère conjoncturel
c'est à dire des choses qu'il
n'emmènerait monsieur virois nous ne
répondions la cei à la question que j'ai
posée je voudrais que l'on que l'on
donne des perspectives d'avenir vous
dites on ne retrouvera pas si vous
voulez qu'on commence pas une excuse si
vous leur donnez votre avis à la fin que
je n'explique pas la réalité de la
situation pour jouer live on vendra
connaissiez oui non mais ces raisons ces
réseaux elles sont mal connues puisque
je suis si critiqué lorsque je fais les
analyses que vous savez mais je vous
donne l'occasion de donner lors des
perspectives éventuellement que les
angloys arty mais de l'espoir
bien sûr de l'espoir sont proprement que
les ti vertes et cynisme pas du tout de
ce manoir pas du tout montré timide je
ne cultive pas le pessimisme
j'essaye de dire la vérité quant à la
situation présente et d'autre part
j'essaye d'imaginer la société nouvelle
que nous avons a construit elle ralentit
pour répondre pour répondre aux attentes
d'activité cette socialiste
il reste alors étant précisé que la
société ancienne c'est fini pour
diverses raisons et pardonnez moi de les
dire qu'ils sont le progrès
technologiques qui sont la fin de grand
bien de consommation qu'on a connue
pendant les trente glorieuses qui sont
la montée des pays en voie de
développement et d'autre part la demande
d'activités féminine qui a augmenté
depuis 1945
de façon tout à fait vertige et la
présidence et la présence d'immigrés en
france le pen
non mais je vous plais à dire 300 mille
demandeurs d'emplois d'origine d'origine
étrangère ou ce n'est vraiment pas ça
qui nous pose lui pose un problème
j'ajoute que les immigrés en situation
régulière ont droit qu elle est à la
stabilité à la dignité du séjour
ils sont pour la plupart en france
depuis plus de dix ans s'ils veulent
rentrer dans leur pays où les aidera
s'ils veulent avec nous s'intégrer dans
notre communauté nationale on met à
brailler et ils auront leur place dans
cette société nouvelle que vous allez
décrire que je vais je vais m'efforcer
n'ont pas de vous décrire une société
nouvelle monsieur du roi mais de vous
dire quelles sont les pistes un chemin
qu'il nous faut emprunter
g chez du moins me semble-t-il le mérite
de dire que si on continue à résonner
comme ont résonné hier le plein emploi
le retour au plein emploi qu'on attend
depuis 1973 on l'attendra pendant encore
au moins autant de temps alors qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire d'abord il faut donner
à l'évidence la priorité à l'entreprise
c'est l'entreprise qui cale en poitou
l'emploi celui qu'elle génère en son
sein et celui qu'elle permet de créer
par son apport à la richesse nationale
et nous menons nous menons une politique
en faveur de l'entreprise
nous avons beaucoup à faire en matière
de situation relative vis-à-vis des pays
concurrents des pays étrangers il y à du
chômage partout dans mot 32 millions
le sommer dans les pays de l' ocde il
n'y a pas de raison qu'on souffre plus
que les autres et les pays qui nous
mangent la laine sur le dos donc il faut
qu'on rétablisse notre situation
arlette et sur ce point des entreprises
vous êtes plutôt satisfait de leur
comportement vous les trouvez timorés
non je suis plutôt satisfait compte tenu
de la conjoncture dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons de leur comportement il
faudra évidemment faire encore davantage
davantage demain et monsieur kaba nous
donner tout à l'heure de la joute à qui
son entourage deuxièmement deuxième au
monde c'est dur parce que sinon avant
goût deuxièmement il faut travailler du
côté de l'aménagement du temps de
travail
il y à d'autres formes de rapports au
travail qu'il faut organiser
je pense évidemment au temps partiel qui
est relativement peu développé dans
notre pays par rapport à des pays
étrangers nous avons nous sommes en
train le rapporteur est ici présents
monsieur pain de faire voter une loi
relative à l'aménagement du temps de
travail qui est très porteuse de ces
nouvelles formes d'organisation du
travail qui sont susceptibles de donner
une activité à plus de gens que par le
passé il faut ensuite que nous
travaillons dans le domaine de la
formation la formation n'est pas une
condition suffisante pour l'emploi c'est
une condition absolument nécessaire en
s'orientant vers trois catégories les
chômeurs de longue durée
ceux qui sont hélas progressivement
exclus actuellement de la communauté de
travail de la communauté nationale et
qui ont des difficultés sociales lourdes
qu'est-ce qu'ils viennent eh bien nous
avons mis en place un projet de loi pour
répondre à leurs problèmes le problème
voyez vous c'est qu'après un an deux ans
de chômage où on assiste souvent à une
étable détérioration psychologique et
parfois belles filles
des individus ils sont leur tendre la
main prévoir des procédures spécifiques
pour tenter de les réinsérer dans
l'activité quitte à ce que ce soit des
activités de caractère réduit moins
rémunérés que le niveau du smic pour
importe il faut leur donner le moyen de
se re responsabiliser le smic ne sera
plus un plancher au big noise 1 et met
pas en cause le smic et je ne mets pas
en cause de smic notamment pour ce qui
concerne le secteur exposé à la
concurrence le secteur classique mais
force est bien de convenir que certains
types d'activités nouvelles ne tour ont
émergé que dans la mesure où on leur
trouve des règles d'un encadrement un
environnement adapté chez parler de la
formation pour les chômeurs de longue
durée pour pour les jeunes les jeunes
nous avons un immense problème que peu
de pays connaissent que nous d'eux d'un
solution de continuité entre la sortie
de l'école et l'entrée dans le monde du
travail
il ya un problème est un problème qu'on
essaye de régler on est en aidant de
régler en est dans l'éducation nationale
à s'adapter à s'ouvrir à des entreprises
en modernisant d'apprentissage quoique
c'est la semaine prochaine que je
présenterai un projet de loi à ce sujet
en favorisant les formations en
alternance et si j'avais être fier de
quelque chose c'est du coup de fouet
formidables vont donner aux formations
en alternance qui permettent aux jeunes
à la fois d'entrer dans l'entreprise et
de continuer à suivre une formation
théorique il ya la formation
j'ai parlé de ses deux premières
catégories je pourrais parler également
des licenciés il faut absolument traiter
les personnes et distanciée des leur
licenciement ne pas les laisser
s'attendait à voir ça veut dire quoi
traiter parce que cet instrument il vous
faut un problème et il faut leur
proposer mais c'est ce que nous faisons
est très long de ce droit les
conventions de conversion c'est à dire
qu'une personne désormais à droit
quelles que soient les conditions dans
lesquelles elle a été
licenciée économique alors que jusqu'à
présent un salarié sur trois licenciés
seulement pouvaient bénéficier d'un plan
social aujourd'hui c'est tout ce qu'ils
ont vocation à bénéficier d'un plan
social convention de conversion c'est ça
moi de bilan évaluation pour le salarié
concerné et de formations adaptées pour
l'activité qu'il peut reproduire à et
enfin en dernier nous faut à l'exemple
de ce qui s'est passé aux états unis et
au japon
développer l'emploi dans les activités
dans le secteur des services depuis 1982
je crois que ce quelque chose comme 10
millions d'emplois qui ont été créés aux
états unis n'ont pas été créés dans
l'industrie n'ont pas été créés dans les
services spécifiques n'ont pas été créés
dans l'agriculture cela va sans dire
ils ont été créés dans de nouveaux types
de services des services de proximité
des services qui ont pour objectif de
d'aider les gens d'aider les mères de
famille d'aider les personnes âgées ces
services il y a deux manières de les
faire se développer
ils peuvent être dans le secteur public
nous encourageons nous sommes arrivés un
chiffre record pour ce qui concerne les
travaux d'utilité collective
nous avons créé avec les projets
d'insertion locale des formules analogue
pour les plus de 26 ans est vrai vous
avez exposé longuement tout le catalogue
est ce que j'ai l'air d'être pessimiste
non merci mais si je comprends bien oui
il y aura demain des emplois classiques
comme dit tout à l'heure
tout à fait les chômeurs et des gens
entre les deux il y aura millions il y
aura un secteur classique il y aura à
côté de ce secteur classique des
demandeurs un premier groupe de gens qui
ne seront pas partie du secteur
classique mais qui seront soit en
formation soit sur une activité
d'attentes du genre de seulement onze
éléments d'information pourquoi et
d'attentes pourquoi pas mais pour une
raison bien si les secteurs des mesures
du roi
jeanne et jean bouin le sud est où une
raison bien sûr c'est qu'à l'heure qu'il
est sur les 2 millions 600 mille
demandeurs d'emploi que nous avons nous
en avons deux catégories une qui nous
fait un très gros problème ce sont huit
cent mille chômeurs de longue durée pour
lesquels les ai pris le projet de loi
auquel je faisais allusion les autres 1
million 800 mille
ce sont des gens qui ont vocation à
rester au chômage pendant quelques
semaines ou quelques mois tout au plus
pour quoi
en raison de l'évolution technologique
dont je n'ai pas eu malheureusement
longuement parlé tout à l'heure parce
que vous m'avez prématurément
interrompue qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que l'évolution
technologique est tellement rapide
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut plus rentrer
dans la vie active en se disant je
rentre dans telle usine je vais y rester
toute ma vie et faire toute ma vie la
même chose ça n'est pas vrai on sera
appelée à changer d'activité a changé de
poste de travail a changé souvent
d'entreprises et même à changer de
région
cette société là nous ne pouvons pas y
échapper alors plutôt que de la subir
essayons de l'organiser et de
l'organiser de la façon la plus positive
possible
donc nous aurons le secteur classique
nous aurons des gens qui devront passer
en tout état de cause dans ces solutions
d'attentes dont je vous parlais c'est à
dire avec de la formation et bien tous
auront soit de la formation choix d'une
activité d'attentes et puis ceux pour
lesquels nous aurons des problèmes de
réinsertion particulier eh bien nous les
utiliserons dans ses activités dans ses
activités de services que nous essayons
de faire réémerger parce que la
différence des états unis elles ne
peuvent pas immergées spontanément en
france du fait de nos règles sociales et
du fait du smic et nous avons besoin de
créer des structures spéciales je pense
notamment aux associations
intermédiaires maintenant pardon de des
questions disparates que je vais vous
poser mais le l'urgence ne fait devoir
accélérer les choses que je vous
montrais des réponses bref
sur un bref retour sur deux points sur
la sécurité sociale n'a pas répondu à
une question d'heure c'est rare mais
tout de même ce nom
la question posée par jean louis le cns
vp jouer l'alcool est ce que vous avez
été géré est-ce que vous donnant un an
vous avez vous avez répondu sur le tabac
est ce que la question était est ce que
vous avez subi la pression de lobbys qui
vous ont empêché trois jeux de subissent
très commun aucune pression et que vous
avez senti dans le non mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai que ça pose un problème
économique
reprenons l'exemple de la publicité pour
le tabac imaginons qu'on interdise la
publicité pour le tabac sous toutes ses
formes et on ne verra plus jamais un
grand prix de formule 1 sur nos passes
de télévision pourquoi parce que la
ligier bon c'est une marque de
cigarettes française dit la patronne
et puis parce que prost il est dans une
voiture qui a des allures de pâques
il faut pas supprimer la publicité pour
la bière sabmiller
je vous ai dit que les décisions
seraient prises en temps voulu lie
encore un autre problème c'est celui de
l' équilibre financier des chaînes on
n'a pas le droit de ne pas le prendre en
considération et est ce que fait mon
poignet droit ou dans les temps avec la
cie ça vous êtes parti à l'expansion non
mais moi je suis très bien où est ce que
il y à inscrire à la série social il n'y
a pas des très grandes distorsions entre
les différents régimes
est ce qu'il n'ya pas des régimes en
france qui sont particulièrement coûteux
et si oui je vous montre le régulateur
par exemple et si oui est ce que vous
envisagez une correction de ces
déséquilibres alors particulièrement
coûteux pourpre est particulièrement
coûteux pourquoi pas non point parce que
les agriculteurs bénéficierait davantage
les habitants pas du tout parce que les
agriculteurs comme d'autres régimes
montent un rapport démographique
défavorable
c'est à dire qu'il ya de plus en plus
d'inactifs du fait de l'évolution dans
les cultures au père 45000 en préparant
dans les îles depuis longtemps il ya de
plus en plus d'inactifs donc de gens qui
on doit
payer des prestations maladie ou des
prestations vieillesse est de moins en
moins de cotisants
mais un des objectifs cotisé ailleurs
mais un des objectifs de la sécurité
sociale des obus des principes qui ont
été posées en 1945 c'était le principe
d'unité
ça voulait dire qu'à défaut de faire un
régime unique de sécurité sociale du
moins il devait y avoir ce qu'on appelle
la compensation démographique
il ya aussi donc c'est normal qu'on a
déjà vécu il ya de plus en plus de
retraités est ce que les cotisations
intègre des social des retraités
devraient être augmentés c'est
effectivement une éventualité à débattre
pendant les pendant les états généraux
ou bien on a un problème dans le train à
vie ou écoutez je me garderai bien de
formuler quelques vies que ce soit mais
nous avons veillé aux idées voulait pas
nous avons un avion je suis là mois pour
définir les problèmes définir les
problèmes de sécurité sociale non mais
vous rêvez pas ce que les aînés mais les
états généraux
vous allez rassemblé plein de gens qui
vont discuter d'une façon très
intéressante et quoi au bout du compte
vous pensez que tout le monde va tomber
d'accord pour certaines solutions qu'ils
avaient une plaie temps de l'insouciance
les amis des français que moi et je dois
dire je dois dire ah on apprend les
paris coup j'attends beau et on les
prend j'attends beaucoup des états
généraux et j'attends d'autant plus des
états généraux que je suis très
favorablement impressionné par le sens
des responsabilités avec lequel les
diverses organisations concernées les
prêts fars je vais même vous parler
écouter de la manifestation d'un
mutualité à dire
réalité c'était pas c'était pas ma fait
si chaud sting bon eh bien je dois vous
dire que j ai entendu des propos
extrêmement responsable lui des
propositions constructives quinté fait
elles valent ce qu'elles valent mais du
moins on n'a pas dit comme premier
socialiste venu là la crise la sécurité
sociale soliste pas c'est la faute à la
droite qui avait pas la droite patrice
de sécurité sociale est bien ce qui est
vrai pour la mutualité vrai pour les
union d'associations familiales est vrai
pour les organisations syndicales et moi
je suis certain qu'on aura un débat
extrêmement riche au cours des états
généraux
je saute un autre sujet le code de
nationalité
il en fut un il faut le réformer il ne
faut pas le réduire jure qu'il faut le
réformer
bien sûr et je suis le mieux placé dans
ce pays pour en parler pourquoi lorsque
l'utilisateur du code de la nationalité
c'est moi c'est moi qui naturalise en
tant que ministre des affaires sociales
je voudrais d'ailleurs félicité qui est
plus de naturalisation exactement
qu'avant cela pour répondre aux
arrière-pensées d'exclusion qu'on prête
au gouvernement avec sa réforme du code
de nationalité baugé dit écoutez moi je
naturalise me diraient les textes ça
vaut dans la qualité de ceux qui les
appliquent pas mais néanmoins avec le
collectif n généralisée plus de gens
qu'on en avait jamais naturalisés au
cours d'une année pendant et ils
vendront les années les années fastes la
réforme du code de nationalité a pour
but de donner le nombre de
naturalisations de revendre de rendre
les procédures moins longue et moins
bureaucratique et d'autre part et c'est
probablement le point central de faire
en sorte qu'on ne devienne pas français
dans la clandestinité ou à son insu
il semble que c'est un objectif tout à
fait la zone est et augmenter le nombre
d'acquisitions de nationalité française
ça vous semble être également l'objectif
de monsieur pasqua mawa de moi je le
coûteux là la france charles pasqua le
sait aussi bien que moi et ils
pourraient vous le dire
vous le redire ici même la france s'est
fait de l'apport de communautés
successives qu'il faut qu'ils font sa
richesse et je vois pas pourquoi demain
ils n'en seraient pas contre vous êtes
favorable à une société multiculturelle
et je suis multi culturelle du tir à
celle là on entre dans des dents des
espèces de définition où j'aurai
quelques peines à savoir la
signification exacte de toute façon est
ce qu'il fallait pour assimiler
wattmètre finish aurait des définitions
si c'est parce que ça vous embarrassent
communes ont sûrement barre à sion mais
non seulement barrage en ayons des
problèmes fondamentaux ne m'embarrasse
pas du tout multiculturelle qu'est ce
qu'on entend par là s'ils encore donné
une excellente encore se réduire encore
des références religieuses bien sûr
gastronomique linguistique ou je ne sais
quoi à une civilisation d'origine moi je
vois pas pourquoi je serais content la
france multiculturelle la france
multiculturelle france multiraciale
m elle est dans les marais dans les
écoles coraniques par elle et elle est
ancrée dans la réalité des faits alors
justement c'est ce qui est d'ailleurs
une des grosses difficultés de notre
politique vis-à-vis des immigrés c'est
qu'on ne peut pas traiter de la même
manière des gens qui ont vocation à
s'intégrer définitivement dans notre
société et à qui on doit impérativement
apprendre le français de manière à ce
qu'ils soient pas demain des déracinés
et d'un autre côté des gens qui ont
vocation à rentrer chez eux
trop souvent on est entre les deux et on
fait des gens fabriquent des gens qui
seront déracinés aussi bien si reste que
s'il repart vous venez de jeu c'est moi
qui ai mentionné charles pasqua ça me
fait penser à une autre question qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé vous dont je le
dis pour le thé les secteurs qui ne
savent pas dont le père a été tué à la
guerre quand vous étiez tout petit
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé du
des déclarations faites par charles
pasqua ou par pierre messmer disant à
propos de tout ce qui entoure l article
2 mai que noir dont on parlait tout à
l'heure que la génération des 40 ans
dont vous êtes avait sans doute des
complexes parce qu'il n'avait pas
participé à ces événements de la guerre
mondiale n'ai pas été choqué non de ce
que je sais ce que je sais au sujet de
charles pasqua puisque vous avez évoqué
le souvenir de mon père effectivement
débarqué en provence c'est qu'ils
auraient pu croiser un champ de pasqua
qui appartenait au maquis à l'époque et
il a préparé notamment ce qui s'est
passé en notant qu est ce que vous
sentez une d'une façon globale
une communauté d'attitude de pensée de
comportement entre la génération des
ministres de 40 ans nous propose sont
une affaire de génération que nous ayons
que nous ayons des références
culturelles ont encore vous savez le
hard rock
non ma non ma fille dont ma fille
raffole j'ai quelques difficultés à en
prêt entrez dedans si j'ose dire non
cela étant en d1 au delà de ses
affinités culturelles de cette histoire
commune
je crois que l'attitude sur les
problèmes ne tient pas aux différences
de générations il n'y a pas une
ouverture particulière un certain nombre
de fonds de la société multiculturelle
par exemple pourrait revenir
je ne crois pas que ce soit une dernière
question des dernières questions comme
ça c'est sur un sujet grave mais c'est
une question que le truc un petit peu un
petit peu légère sur un sujet aussi
grave qu est ce que vous pensez de
l'initiative du président du mouvement
des radicaux de gauche qui a déjeuné
tout récemment avec des malades du sida
c'était une manière comme une autre de
répondre
à la tentative de désinformation dans
mon prédécesseur dont se fait donc vous
êtes plutôt solide des raisons générales
de son geste
cauchon niche que tu peux tu pas son
petit peu tic bien nous sommes submergés
de questions il a longtemps qu'il n'ait
pas eu autant de questions des
téléspectateurs et nous allons
maintenant des paroles un petit peu
agent lui la scène charles v scène
quelques questions oui depuis le temps
que l'on parle de la retraite à la carte
pourquoi at on laissé le projet de côté
tout simplement parce que ce sont des
affaires qui ne se met pas en place
aussi facilement
il y a il y à prévoir par définition
pour ceux qui vont avoir une activité
une incitation financière pour
poursuivre leurs activités
il faut veiller à ce que ce que cela
pourra coûter aux régimes de sécurité
sociale ne soit pas plus élevé que ce
que ça lui fera économiser mais de toute
façon en matière de retraite pour qu'une
mesure puisse se produire ses effets par
définition il faut un nombre d'années à
ses considérants d'autres questions que
pensez-vous de l'enfance yves leclère et
grandes surfaces concernant la
parapharmacie et certains médicaments et
bien entendu souviendrait pas cette
information quittera la question écoutez
il est un certain nombre de produits qui
ne peuvent être vendus ailleurs que dans
une officine et l'esprit alors je
comprends
l' enthousiasme que peuvent avoir
certains responsables de grandes
surfaces se disant qu'il ferait
peut-être aussi bien que d'autres mais
je crois qu'il faut être très attentifs
à la sauvegarde d équilibre très délicat
auquel nous sommes parvenus
ça veut dire que vous admettez quand
même que certains médicaments peuvent
être dans des grandes surfaces et pense
qu'on appelle un médicament vous avez eu
des problèmes que j'ai eus avec monsieur
cabane tout à l'heure pour apporter une
définition une autre question
on vous demande si vous vous trouvez
normal dans la différence considérable
entre le coût des verres de lunettes et
le remboursement de ceux-ci par la
sécurité sociale
les lunettes sont elles un objet de luxe
c'est vrai qu' il n'y a pas de quoi être
fier de notre système de sécurité
sociale du sort qui est fait à la
lunetterie peut-être même si ce sort est
meilleur à la à la dentisterie
c'est incontestablement un des gros
défauts de notre système les chacun
comprendra que ce n'est pas dans les
circonstances financières présentes que
je puisse que les gestionnaires du
système puisse prendre des initiatives
dont pourtant je reconnais bien
volontiers la légitimité sur le sel
avant dernière question pourquoi les
vignettes bleues des salariés du régime
général sont elles rembourser à 40%
alors que les mêmes médicaments continué
à être remboursé à 70% pour les salariés
des mines et de la sncf
parce que comme je l'expliquais tout à
l'heure où j'ai essayé de l'expliquer
tout à l'heure la sécurité sociale et
une est une mosaïque en réalité et un
certain nombre de régimes préexistait à
la sécurité sociale c'est le cas par
exemple pour les mines et ils ont gardé
leurs propres règles si vous voulez les
régimes de sécurité sociale le peuvent
schématiquement se répartir en trois
grandes catégories les régimes spéciaux
hérité de régime qui existait avant que
la sécurité sociale de swat et le régime
général qui a été créé avec la sécurité
sociale et d'autre part les régimes
particuliers qui sont venus après le
régime
général alors ces régimes spéciaux ont
gardé certaines particularités mais il
n'ya pas que des avantages dans leur
système
alors la dernière question la dernière
question lors d'une émission récente on
a demandé à monsieur bérégovoy combien
il gagne est ce qu'il faisait de son
argent à fleurier vous ce genre de
question est est ce que vous êtes prêts
à y répondre
ont sûrement je dois gagner quelque
chose comme 31 ou 32 mille francs par
mois c'est à dire huit fois moins qu'un
journaliste vedette sur une autre chaîne
que celle ci via la mer devant un mot
sur 28 des gens votre phrase sur une
autre chaîne que celui ci une dernière
raison n'ait pas réagi au cours d'une
heure et demie d'émission à une phrase
de l'introduction de france emmène vers
ie 10 ans que vous seriez le premier
ministre dans tous les cas de figure à
l'élection présidentielle et vous des
matignon matignon c'est cette affaire de
circonstances c'est cette affaire de
capacité pour les circonstances on verra
bien pas même pour les capacités laissez
moi le temps d'en faire autant bah c'est
pas non croit bon ben voila voila le
venue l'heure du verdict monsieur mise
du verdict des téléspectateurs que la
sofres ondes levier demandé qu'on vous
donne une deuxième chance une question
dont vous estimiez que été posée trop
tôt avant vous deviez vous n'ayez le
temps d'argumenter malheureusement pas
de chance pour vous allez voir c'est pas
terrible
votre pouvoir de conviction sur cette
question là alors je recherche la
question est ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on
peut l'envoyer
voilà c'est le jugement sur les mesures
récentes sur la sécurité sociale dont je
me souviens plus exactement de la
question mais c'était est ce que vous
considérez que ces mesures sont
acceptables et plus gouvernement a eu
raison de les prendre ou inacceptables
et que finalement ils auraient dû faire
autre chose eh bien voyez vous vous
passer de 35 à 36%
ce qui n'est pas statistiquement
significatifs à sochaux c'est que vous
faites bouger un certain nombre de
statistiquement c'est statistiquement
significatif mais ça d'ailleurs jérôme
jaffré pas douter une petite explication
tout à leur avoue jérôme jaffré g rouge
afrique et directeur des études
politiques de la sofres bien monsieur
seguin a traité ce soir des deux
dossiers qui passionne le plus les
français
la sécurité sociale et le chômage est
bien sûr nous avons posé des questions
sur ce point et enregistrer les
réactions à chaud des échantillons de la
sofres et faut-il le rappeler ces
réactions à chaud c'est à la fois
l'intérêt mais c'est aussi la limite de
nos sondages
alors monsieur seguin s'est il montré
convaincant sur les grands dossiers
qu'il a avorté
nous avons posé la question sur la
sécurité sociale bien sûr le chômage est
aussi les problèmes politiques au sein
de la majorité
et compte tenu de la difficulté des
dossiers traités il est intéressant de
noter que les avis positifs et négatifs
s'équilibrent à peu près la différence
n'est pas statistiquement significative
cela signifie que les avis positifs et
les avis négatifs s'équilibre sur la
sécurité sociale et sur le chômage
curieusement c'est sur les problèmes au
sein de la majorité que monsieur séguin
est jugé le moins convaincant peut être
sa sérénité
n'est-elle pas partagé par les français
sur ce point deuxième série de questions
est ce que les efforts que demande le
gouvernement sont demandés surtout aux
défavorisés surtout aux privilégiés où
est-ce qu'ils sont équitablement réparti
entre tous les français
nous avons posé cette question juste
avant le début de l'émission et nous
l'avons posée dans le dernier quart
d'heure pour voir sur ce point si
monsieur sega avait fait bouger
l'opinion
on constate et c'est intéressant que une
légère majorité estiment que les efforts
sont surtout demander aux catégories
défavorisées
pratiquement personne estime que c'est
demander aux catégories privilégiées
42 % qu'ils sont demandés à tous les
français pas de variation significative
sur ce point en cours d'émission
comme il n'y avait pas de variation
statistiquement significative sur les
mesures acceptables ou inacceptable ce
qui signifie que sur ce point de
l'acceptation des mesures ou de la
répartition des efforts des français
monsieur séguin ce soir n'a pas réussi à
convaincre la majorité
de l'opinion sur des dossiers il faut le
souligner tout de même extrêmement
difficile ce qui est intéressant
maintenant c'est la performance
personnelle de monsieur séguin
précisément parce qu'ayant traiter de
ces problèmes difficiles
les téléspectateurs l'ont mieux connu en
une heure et demie nous avons posé notre
question traditionnelle bonnes opinions
mauvaises opinions juste avant le début
de l'émission et nous l'avons posée dans
les dernières dix minutes bonne opinion
à l'égard de monsieur séguin avant le
début de l'émission 44 mauvaise 27 à la
fin 57 % de bonnes opinions 30 % de
mauvaises un mouvement donc de 13 points
57 % de bonnes opinions à la fin de
l'émission c'est une des bonnes
performances de l'heure de vérité qui
place monsieur séguin parmi les bons
performers sur le plan de la performance
médiatique de l'émission
dernière question enfin comme en classe
ton sur l'échiquier politique monsieur
séguin puisque c'est une question qui
divise souvent les journalistes et la
presse
est ce qu'on considère que monsieur
séguin se classent à droite au centre à
gauche ou en dehors des classifications
politique habituelle
là le gaulliste qui est monsieur séguin
va souffrir car il n'est pas classé en
dehors des classifications politique
habituelle au contraire une large
majorité 55 % de l'échantillon
statistiquement tout à fait significatif
le classent à droite parfait merci
jérôme jaffré alors cette émission roger
meece a été programmé ce soir donc dix
mois mercredi prochain 10 vous serez
libre pour aller la finale de la coupe
de france avec michel hidalgo et à sa
blonde autres personnes sur des îles de
sal et moi je sais que vous y tenez jean
marie le pen y sera quelle sera votre
attitude vis-à-vis de lui je ne crois
pas que la discourtoisie la porte bien
eh bien c'était donc l'heure de vérité
de monsieur philippe séguin qui va
maintenant essayer sur la tradition le
livre d'or avec nous prochain rendez
vous le mercredi 1er juillet bonsoir
[Musique]